el cirujano realizará una histeroscopía
para ver el interior de su útero
la histeroscopia puede usarse para
diagnosticar o corregir un problema en
el útero sin que se necesite hacer una
incisión en el abdomen el útero es un
órgano hueco del abdomen inferior donde
crece el bebé durante un embarazo
cada mes durante los años fértiles de
una mujer la capa interna de su útero
llamada endometrio acumula sangre
adicional y tejido para prepararse para
el embarazo
si el embarazo no ocurre el tejido extra
es eliminado a través de la vagina
durante la menstruación
una histeroscopía de diagnóstico se
puede realizar para evaluar las causas
de una hemorragia uterina anormal
investigar posibles causas de
infertilidad o abortos repetidos
o detectar bultos benignos o no
cancerosos en su útero como fibroides
pólipos cicatrices o malformaciones una
histeroscopía operatoria se puede
realizar para retirar bultos benignos
del útero
obtener una muestra de tejido o biopsia
de las paredes del útero
ubicar un dispositivo intrauterino diu o
colocar pequeños dispositivos en las
trompas de falopio como una forma de
control de natalidad permanente antes de
su procedimiento es posible que reciba
anestesia general regional o local
el médico empezará insertando un
espéculo para separar las paredes de la
vagina luego el médico jalar a el cuello
del útero hacia la entrada de la vagina
después el médico utilizará instrumentos
llamados dilatadores para abrir el
cuello del útero
el médico guiará un histeroscopio un
dispositivo delgado equipado con una
cámara y una luz a través de la vagina y
hacia el útero la cámara transmitirá
imágenes del útero en una pantalla
el médico inyectar a gas o líquido para
expandir el útero facilitando la
localización de tejido anormal en su
útero en una histeroscopia de
diagnóstico el médico utilizará el
listeros copió para examinar el interior
del útero en una esteros copia
operatoria el médico insertará pequeñas
herramientas a través del esteros copio
para tomar una biopsia extraer un bulto
como un pólipo o tratar otros problemas
después del procedimiento es posible que
el médico recomiende analgésicos debería
poder retomar sus actividades normales
después de uno o dos días de su
procedimiento es posible que tenga
cólicos suaves y un poco de flujo de
sangre por varios días